once my mother's girlfriend actually
went into the ground that was the first
time that I actually cried yeah there
was never another time
I've been dropping Bombshells during the
Press tour for his memoir
Memoir and one topic that keeps popping
up his mother the late Princess Diana
Diana seems to be a theme that came up
in the Netflix docu series and is
clearly a very important theme running
through spare it's very clear that he's
not able to let go of the ghost of his
mother he talks about her continuously
in Harry's ITV interview he read an
excerpt from the tell-all book going
into detail about the moment his father
then Prince now King Charles told him
his mom died Harry was just 12 years old
there was then a shift internally
I began silently pleading with poor or
God or both no no no
Pollock down into the folds of the old
quilts and blankets and sheets
there were complications
mommy was quite badly injured and taken
to hospital darling boy
he always called me darling boy
but he was saying it quite a lot now so
I think it's really important that he
has read his own story it's incredibly
emotive it's very raw it's um it's
tragic to read it and and you sense this
little boy this 12 year old boy who's
hearing something that he doesn't want
to hear yeah and Harry says looking back
at that moment played a part in his
decision to step away from his Royal
role alongside wife Meghan Markle I
don't want history to repeat itself I do
not want to be a single dad
and I just certainly don't want my
children to have a life without a mother
or a father
just moving passages in the book are
about
Diana and the
on Harry how it shapes the man he is and
how even now he seems to be desperately
searching for answers turns out Harry
and his brother Prince William didn't
believe their mom was dead a confession
he made on 60 Minutes with Anderson
Cooper for a long time I just refused to
accept that she was she was gone
um part of you know she would never do
this to us but also part of maybe this
is all part of a plan I mean you really
believe that maybe she had just decided
to disappear for a time for a time and
then that she would call us and we would
go and join her
how long did you believe that
yes many many years and William and I
talked about it as well
he had he had similar thoughts what's so
evident in all of this is is this huge
struggle Harry has had in coming to
terms with his mother's death and that
grief that was unprocessed for for more
than 20 years and agreed that he clearly
still struggles with and loss that he
feels very acutely that pain is still
very real and I think that comes across
uh so much in the telling of his story
and to get some more answers about
Diana's death Harry visited the tunnel
in Paris where her fatal car accident
played out and did something daring I
wanted to see whether it was possible
driving at the speed that Henry Paul was
driving that you could lose control of a
car and plow into a pillow
killing almost everybody in that car I
need to take this journey I need to ride
the same route the same tunnel the same
speed all of it William and I considered
reopening the inquest because there were
so many gaps and so many holes in it
which just didn't add up and didn't make
sense would you still like to do that
I don't even know if it's an option now
but no I think
would I like to do that now it's a hell
of a question Anderson it's only a few
years back he reached out to a medium to
try and communicate with his mother he
details how he drove through the alma
tunnel on several occasions trying to
understand what happened trying to work
out if this was an accident and I think
it's heartbreaking to read that Harry
claims he hasn't cried about losing his
mom since
I think it's bizarre because I see
William and me smiling
I remember the gills
that I felt guilty about the fact that
the people that we were meeting
were showing more emotion than
we were showing once my mother's coffin
actually went into the ground that was
the first time that I actually cried
yeah there was never another time all
three year teenagers you didn't cry
about it no two things really come
across in all of this one is that he
he's never really gotten over losing his
mother but that's something he struggled
with his entire life and the second
struggle is the struggle with being
despair it's all there in the title and
from the past to the present Harry's
current strained relationship with his
brother William took center stage on
Good Morning America how would your mom
feel about your relationship with your
brother now yep he talks about what
their mother would think if she were
alive today I think she would be
heartbroken
that has ended up where it's ended up I
think she'd be heartbroken
about the fact that William
his office were part of these stories
and William and I made a made a pact we
made a deal that no matter what we would
never let our officers fight against
each other I think she would be
devastated that
that talking that the relationship seems
to have broken down so much that any
chance of a Reconciliation looks
unlikely and I think it's also worth
pointing out that while Diana also
pushed at Royal boundaries she also gave
damaging television interviews and
contributed to a book that that really
did put the monarchy in crisis Harry
says he believes in the monarchy he
believes in the future of the monarchy
but everything he's doing seems to
suggest otherwise
[Music]
foreign
[Music]